- So perhaps my favorite
story over the weekend
was that John Roberts, Chief
Justice of the Supreme Court,
was screaming at the other Justices
saying that they have to dismiss
the Texas versus Pennsylvania case
that I covered last week.
This story was obvious nonsense
for many different reasons.
The first, as I covered in the video,
is that the case was absolute nonsense.
It didn't fit the court's jurisdiction.
The court effectively voted
nine to zero to get rid of it.
No one was going to grant cert on this.
The second is that the Supreme
Court simply doesn't leak.
You never hear from the insides,
mainly because the court clerks
care about their reputation
and wanna work for really fancy law firms.
So they're not going to leak.
And the third is that they
couldn't scream in person
because they didn't meet in person.
The Supreme Court hasn't
been meeting in person
or even holding oral
arguments in person for months
because of COVID.
But if you want some Christmas cheer,
check out this video I
did on all the laws broken
in National Lampoon's Christmas Vacation,
and I'll see you in court.